like oh god man this guy's four stitches
open in the gym y-yeah well ii also digi
then you can just be like what the [ __ ]
it's messed up so i just got back into
contact with a friend of mine that I
haven't seen in like years yeah yeah
like it was a buddy of mine that I
haven't seen since I was younger like we
both lived in wood Hill which is a
department community here in town and
like officially our family's like
separated like they yeah it looks really
messed up like they parted ways and I
hadn't talked to him for a long time but
like I'll be honest man like one of the
biggest reasons why I hung out with him
was to like hang out with his sister
because she was super hot even now like
how she's like bangin hot dude he's like
watching this right now whoa no talking
to him anymore
no no I mean no it's not a I don't think
he really gets on YouTube or anything
but I mean I hadn't talked to him in
forever
he was good to talk to him over the
phone and we've been trying to get
together but it's just been really
difficult to do because the schedules
and he's got a family now and so on but
yeah dude his sister man god this is her
just like she yeah man it was nuts how
gorgeous she was but even then like like
at the time like I was like 18 years old
and maybe like 17 years old or something
like that and so I think she was like 16
I can't rough top my head but like I was
digging her so much like I was I was
digging this girl so much and like like
it was I was at that at that point you
know like when you're young like when
you're when you're like 16 17 years old
like you'll find some girl and you'll be
like this girl's amazing and then you're
just like follow her around yeah yeah
man like like it's the equipment of what
kids do now where like they Facebook
stalk accept it like I didn't hang out
outside of her house and like the rocks
your window and stuff but but like I
would I'd call over there because at
that time like there weren't cell phones
like there were house phones and so he
called over there and hope you're not on
the internet so you know
[ __ ] yes you would yes you would but I I
hit her I called him called him up a few
times like hey man are you home and he
was like yeah dude come on over and I'm
like all right
I wonder if Jessica's there and I was
there and hang out but yeah man things
went south with her so bad it's weird
man like I don't know see everybody I
think everybody like screws up and does
dumb stuff oh absolutely
up until I got in my first couple
relationships I was like exactly like
that would like every girl it was bad
well but see that's the thing like like
after our family split up because we
both went all of us went to Henry Clay
like that's where my sister and Jess and
her brother Nick like we all went to
Henry Clay and we hung out and so on and
then like my family moved to the other
side of town and Nick's family stayed in
wood Hill for a little while then they
moved away and they started going to
Lafayette and so we were going to like
two totally separate schools and you
know I kept going to him to clay and so
like we thought of contact for like a
long time and then actually call her up
we got Ike in a contact here and there
like it was sporadic it wasn't nearly as
consistent as it had previously been but
like I called her up one day and at the
time like at this time I was maybe 19 or
20 and her boyfriend at the time
answered the phone and I was I was like
hey is just there he's like who's this I
said this is Rob like we've been friends
for a long time and he says I don't want
you calling here anymore
and like hung up the phone now at the
time aren't keep in mind at the time
like I'm I'm a [ __ ] like I'm nowhere
near I got nowhere near had a level of
confidence in myself that I have now and
so at the time I was like punkin I
couldn't talk to her anymore yeah just
imagine Oh No
like okay no let me tell you something
my friend back when I was in high school
I was styling and profiling all right
back in the day I'm loafer you remember
these at all but back in the day having
like those patent leather pullovers like
hoodies with the things to have and I
had one did I bought it was a FUBU one
and it said I said I said what the hell
was that
I remember that did you burp hmm it was
like some weird sound that I heard I
kind of went oh oh oh movie was made
anyway um but yeah I was I was a style
and like it was his patent-leather it
was FUBU and it said Brooklyn on the
front of it and and I thought it was hot
stuff like in hindsight I look like a do
I look like a fool and I was I had like
a fake gold chain awful it just had like
FUBU written on the front or I'm sorry I
had FUBU on the back on the front it
said Brooke went across the front of it
and it was blue and you know cuz at the
time I thought I was hardcore like
running with Gators and stuff but there
were some legit gangbangers but let me
tell you something man like they like I
was not cut out I was not come from that
same cloth and anyway so so as time goes
on like like after that like after her
boyfriend at the time told me not to
call back like I didn't call her again
like I didn't talk to her again for like
seven years or something stupid like
that she's still dead you still with
that guy
actually she's not but it's actually
ironic you say that because I got my
gonna contact with her again later on
and I have just like randomly sent her a
text out of the blue I was like I wonder
what jess is doing these days I sent her
text and I was like hey what's going on
this is Rob and she was like hey what's
going on Rob and I was like she
remembers me awesome you know because
again like like when I was young up
until about five years ago I didn't have
a whole lot of confidence and finally
like you know I started talking to her
again and we started hanging out and
come to find out like she'd moved on
with her life like she had a son now and
she was engaged to be married and I was
like
yeah that sucks yeah I was I was crushed
because I always felt like I'd like I
should have been the one that she got
engaged to you and I don't know it was
like yeah it was like this this
schoolboy crush that has never got past
but like the more I talked to her the
more I was just like man this girl's a
catch because she was super smart and
she was I can't remember which one it
like their psychology and psychiatry I
don't know which one it does that you
have to go to medical school for but
whichever one doesn't prescribe
medication is one that you have to go to
medical school for yeah well not to be a
psychiatrist means you you like write
prescriptions and medications and things
to be a psychologist is like the study
of the mind okay then she was she was
doing psychology and yeah like she has
she had her [ __ ] in gear like she had
her [ __ ] going on and and I would talk
to her but like I'm not in the business
of jumping between people who were in a
relationship like yes just that's not my
business and so you know I kept a
respectful distance I was like look you
know they're doing their own thing and
then and then I so real talk real talk
for a second Dave so like four years ago
my mom died like she died of cancer oh
yeah it was rough and so like she was a
really nice friend and she talked to me
and helped me through it and everything
and like it was it was cool you know but
it was like two years after my mom had
died that I did like finally sunk in you
know they didn't happen and like I got
into this really bad way like I got into
like I got was really depressed so for
like I don't know seven or eight months
I was just really really really
depressed and not like clinical
depression you know in the sense that
like I wouldn't move around all the time
and and that's I think that's what like
one of the misconceptions when it comes
to like people who think that people are
depressed there was like oh all they
want to do is like kill themselves and
sleep yeah you were just really sad yeah
and like it wasn't like that you wanted
to slit your wrists die yeah no no no
like you were just really sad yeah like
the weird thing about like when you're
depressed is is that like I don't know
it's kind of harder than hard to explain
it's like somebody flicked off a light
switch that makes you you
you know what I mean like your
personality and all that kind of stuff
so I stopped talking to my family for
months like I didn't talk to my friends
for months and and she was one of the
people that I just gave that I just gave
hell to like I remember what it was I
was sitting at work one day and we were
texting about something and like she had
said something that irritated me or
something like that as told her like I
don't want to talk to you anymore
like I never want to talk to you again
and she was like she was crushed I know
she was devastated like the last thing
she called you called me a loser yeah
she was like you she called me a like
loser and I was like I mean you know
whatever but yeah like I always I always
feel bad about it so I make it to get
where there's some time hit her up and
apologize but I feel like man would
never have a relationship like that
though what do you mean like I would
never hit up my best friend have an
argument with them and not talk to them
for like three or four months
well you got a room and mine was a
difference yes but at the same time like
like my best friends from from like way
back like we still talk like we've been
friends since I was two and he was one
years old like their it it was like a
real like lifetime friendship and
anyways like we would fight and crap but
I think the longest fight we ever had
was like two hours and and like I don't
even remember what it was about but
whenever I have a friendship with like a
woman or a girl
like we would fight and like it would
just like get way like out of control
and we would hold it against each other
for like a good like two or three weeks
yeah but never happens with the guys
right I think I don't know like if it
happens the same way with two women like
they'd never fight like that
but I don't know it's just one of those
things where
I guess I feel that it was it was kind
of strange looking back at and I don't
know why it is hmm I mean it's I get
that like with most most guys like most
guys don't usually hold grudges like
most guys are you - like you argue for a
little bit and then you just like even
like be in a fight like a real physical
fighter but like there have been times
when I've seen two guys like on the
ground just like punching the crap out
of each other and they get up and
they're like oh that's cool well yeah
yeah over that like an in middle school
it was like that like like two guys
would get into a fight at the beginning
of the year like me and this kid siren
we we got into a fight at the beginning
of the year and I beat the hell out of
each other and then we were friends for
like the rest of the year after that we
just saw because I don't know maybe it's
like you earn people's respect maybe
it's like like I was thinking about that
the other day about like school systems
and school systems are a lot like prison
did you ever watch a TV show called Oz
back in the day now okay
Oz was a 90s TV show on HBO it came on
around the same time we a little bit
earlier or somewhere around the same
time as the wire and so this was back in
the 90s when when like HBO was like the
best best place to like watch anything
really good like there was really really
good stuff on all the time and in Oz was
about like life and the in the prison
system but it was different yeah it was
a drama but the way it was set up is you
had the Oswald Correctional Institute
and then inside the Oswald Correctional
Institute you had what they called
Emerald City which was this small
section where you had a group of
prisoners from all different facets so
you had like the white Aryans and you
had the African Americans and you had
the mobsters and you had people who were
mixed heritage and you had like pretty
much like every major group that would
be represented that what you think would
be in a prison system was in Oz and they
had a lot more freedom than people in
like general population they get spent
on outside of their cells and all that
kind of good stuff and they could they
had they had a lot more freedom overall
but the the way it played out is like
people would get in there and like you
would immediately have to like kill
somebody or beat somebody up or do
something to demonstrate that you
deserve to be respected either that or
you went in with a reputation like when
you and in when you
in there people already knew who you
were like they knew you were like a made
guy outside of the prison system and so
when you got in like you immediately had
respect but but like middle school is a
lot of the same way like middle school
isn't a lot of the same way as a prison
system you get in there and then people
start giving you flak I don't know but
they start giving you flak and so you
just gotta like beat the hell out of
somebody like make people understand
that you're not somebody to be trifled
with and then people will start giving
you the respect now it sucks that you
have to resort to violence to earn
respect but I mean that's kind of a lie
that's just a reflection of a multitude
of things that's a reflection just like
basic human psychology that's a
reflection of the way school systems are
set up where you have like teachers that
don't want to be there
you've got administration's that are for
the most part like you know absentee
from what actually goes on inside the
school you've got parents that are too
busy working to keep track of what your
kids are doing like you've got you've
got basically kids orders like raising
themselves well and and not to mention
all the hormones yeah let's start you've
got like one really gorgeous girl and
you've got all the all the boys in
school vying for her attention like
somebody's gonna get their ass kicked
somebody's gonna get the hell beat out
of them and get pushed down to the
bottom of the wrong and that's just how
it goes
that's just the circle of life and I
think that's one of the problems with
like this whole bullying thing this
whole like anti-bullying campaign like
sure there are kids who get bullied
there sure it needs to stop but
sometimes you just can't reason with
people but you know some men just can't
be bullied or reasoned with some men
just want to watch the world burn that's
why it is like sometimes you just can't
talk out your problems sometimes you
just have to beat the hell out of a
person to make them understand they need
to leave you alone and that's you know
that's not earned it when I was young
and that's the that's the offset like
that's the difference here like you have
a lot of parents who I think rely on the
school system to just take care of stuff
you were just like well Maya the school
systems will teach my kids know what's
right and wrong and you know I'll do the
best that I can but I'm working
full-time and my husband or wife is
working full-time and we don't have time
to monitor every single kid every single
thing our kids do so they pawn it off on
this notion of
well it takes a community to raise a
child to a degree that's true but what
you run into is a circumstance where you
have kids effectively like trying to
govern themselves
you've got school systems that are
overwhelmed because there's just not
enough people to take care of the kids
that are there there's not enough
resources not enough supplies again you
have like administration that's just not
there and so you have this like
pandemonium rules kind of society and
it's wild when you sit down and you look
at it because you're talking about you
know like 12 13 14 year old kids like
figuring out that the best way to solve
their problems is to fight one another
and fighting should be a last resort
like fighting somebody it should be
something like where you feel you have
no other choice
there nods walking away like like you
can't walk away you can't talk to them
you can't reason with them there's
nothing else you can do well then you
just you know try to beat them up but I
think that a lot of kids just don't
understand that like a lot of kids you
know like for whatever reason their life
sucks like maybe their parents are
really shitty to them you know maybe
like you feel like nobody cares or maybe
they're you know the child of divorce
and they're just acting out like that's
not I was when I was a kid like I was a
child of divorce my parents split and my
dad moved us back here my mom bailed out
and we didn't see her for like three
years and so like I was really angry and
and I would act out all the time it was
the only way I knew how to express my
frustration you know because I was I'd
gone from like this ultra liberal
lifestyle in Seattle to like this super
conservative place in Lexington oh yeah
and so it was like this extreme
dichotomy like on one side you had
liberalism on the other side yet you've
sobered ISM and it was just like BAM you
know just switch from one to the other
no gray area I know like you know
working your way into it and so you had
these kids who determined respect by who
was like the most capable and who could
fight the best and so that's what that's
what we ended up running into is I would
get into fights you know to just
demonstrate the fact that I'm not
somebody to screw around with it's like
I said man it's weed when you get into
it you know because it's like you look
at you look at kids and kids are the
best best like depiction of what they're
like how the mind works because kids say
what they think like there's no filter
there they just say stuff like the
Internet's the best way to go
if you want to see what the the human if
you want to see like the human condition
is like and it's absolutely most purest
form look at the internet like people
say what they want when they want how
they want because there's no
consequences for it aside for maybe you
know getting on and saying like you
built a bomb and you're gonna go blow
something up then of course you know
there's ways for them to find you but if
you're on a form I mean that's people in
their most pure form some people are
really nice some people are really
really shitty but it's it's weird when
you when you get down to a bit but
nonetheless yeah man like like everybody
I think everybody screws I mean
everybody makes mistakes and the time
may come when I may hit up Jessica and I
may say I'm you know go to were and just
say I'm sorry because I think one of the
most important lessons I've learned so
far in life is that a man can't be a man
unless he can admit when he's wrong but
I mean obviously I was wrong I mean I
can't really justify my actions with the
whole thing last time we talked but I
don't know if I could face her I don't
know if I could I could deal with that
but we should yeah I should I know I
should but I live life without regrets
live life without I mean that we'll see
that's the thing man like like what I'm
really hoping for like this is my wish
with this whole YouTube thing is I can
do this for a living and if I can I'm
gonna move out west I'm gonna move away
from Lexington and I'm never gonna come
back I may come back to it as a family
but most everybody that I know here will
probably never see me again and like I
want to start fresh I want to do every
year over I want to move out west find a
girl sort of family settle down and so
on and so I think that if I do that it's
important that I make amends to the
people that I've kind of made mistakes
with over the years and there's been a
lot the price of growing up is a heavy
price but